now what has collapsed faster the border
or biden's popularity well the border
has been effectively open since january
20th and it's gotten progressively worse
but biden's slide downward has been even
more stark a new poll by pew shows his
approval went from 55 in july
to 44 in september
meanwhile his disapproval numbers went
from 43 to 53
all told that's a negative swing of 21
points
in just two months
now these findings track what gallup had
reported earlier
and worse for him he lost 13 points
among democrats and democrat leaning
independents
it's not just about afghanistan though
it's about everything
inflation
unemployment
gas prices we all see those and of
course the border
and what's the official white house
reaction to this news
we're we're in the middle of navigating
and weathering storms and and dealing
with crises that's what people were
elected elected him to get through
well all of these storms are of his own
making
most obviously the breakdown at our
border
for more than two decades a small group
of us warned republicans about doing any
immigration deal with the democrats that
doesn't believe in border enforcement
heck they don't believe really in
borders at all we see that now
of course at the time we were called
xenophobic and anti-immigrant and that's
just by the bush people
turns out though we were actually right
is no way to see the footage from del
rio as anything but clear evidence that
the democrat party has completely
surrendered to the open borders lobby
under biden our border has just become
one giant migrant campsite it's filthy
squalid with hundreds more arriving
every day
the ap spilled the beans about the fact
that few are actually being returned to
their home country
haitians have been freed on a very very
large scale in recent days one official
said and tuesday the official who was
not authorized to discuss the matter
uh spoke on the condition of anonymity
put the figure in the thousands
but again that's not good enough
for the democrats who are open borders
radicals they want more lawlessness they
want even less border security and they
want immediate resettlement into the u.s
of anyone who sets foot on our soil
thus they reach their favorite they
reach for their favorite security
blanket which is race
haitian lives are black lives and if we
truly believe that black lives matter
then we must reverse course
the biden administration must
immediately and indefinitely halt all
deportations of haitian migrants
welcome to the blm vacation of the
border
she's effectively saying that skin color
should trump us immigration law
now by that logic
does that mean any black or brown skin
person should be sent to the front of
the line for legal immigration processes
too i bet they'd say yes
and if there's a race angle to play you
can always count on al sharpton to throw
accelerant on the fire
his latest target border agents
patrolling the tough terrain on
horseback
because of course if you're on horseback
near a river and you're using reigns
you're automatically a
racist city del rio is a loving caring
community we don't want your racism in
texas get out of here
nobody wants to hear your racism
[Music]
well remember the majority of the border
agents happen to be hispanic they've
been using horses at the border for
decades
now sharpton's presence in a squad
squawking
that's a gift to biden why because it's
an opportunity for him to tack to the
middle
yeah but of course he squandered it
because biden had the chance to distance
himself from the open borders radicals
in his party he had a chance to stand up
for the rule of law in american
sovereignty
but instead he hid from the press and
sent sake out to embarrass herself once
again
the secretary also conveyed to civil
rights leaders earlier this morning that
we would no longer be using horses in
del rio so that is something a policy
change that has been made in response
this is just
a completely pathetic
we have female migrants being raped by
the cartels children's lives being in
danger during the treks we have major
health care issues being exacerbated
all the while the american people are
left on the hook for billions to deal
with
and horses are their focus
incompetence mixed with radicalism is a
very dangerous combination
it's so bad in texas right now that the
white house itself doesn't seem to even
know what its own policy is
how is border patrol determining right
now who actually gets to stay in and get
processed and who gets expelled under
title 42. the determination of who can
be expelled or not is determined by a
number of factors including the makeup
of the specific family unit some people
with kids who are younger than a certain
age are not accepted back in certain
countries each is made on a case-by-case
basis another determining factor is
detention capacity both within ice and
cpb or when capacity issues and
processing backlogs arise they may be
processed via an alternate means
what
is this gobbledygook
in other words send a message to the
world that
i'm not trump
we love migrants that's essentially what
she's saying a lot of factors come into
play migrants come in record numbers
they overwhelm the system then because
the system is overwhelmed they release
the migrants be they haitians or
hondurans they release them into the
country everybody knows this game
the cartels know it the migrants and the
democrats themselves know the game
and now as we see from those polls so do
the american people
this is not going to end well for
america or the democrats
on everything from the budget to the
border the white house should be
standing with the people like joe
manchin and kristen cinema democrats in
the middle doing so would reassure
americans
and actually help his approval numbers
now looking back we see that it was a
colossal mistake when early on biden
didn't make it clear to the squad that
his administration would not be held
hostage by them
giving in to their threats
only made the squad angrier and more
radical
now when democrat voters rejected bernie
and warren remember in the in the
primaries and they supported biden the
democrat voters were rejecting socialism
and open borders and racial polarization
they didn't want that
but now
with a weakened joe biden cowed by the
lunatics in his own party
that's exactly what those voters are
getting
and by refusing to change course
biden just looks
limp and weak and fanatical at the same
time if that's possible
the political fallout is so dire that
it's even spilling over into the
virginia governor's race right now
and yet
they just keep hitting the accelerator
this my friends is the definition of
insanity
ron klein biden's chief of staff seems
to think that placating the press though
is what will ultimately save them
but the press they seem just as
miserable and unsatisfied as everyone
else's
these are
images that are traumatizing haitian
americans that he promised to treat
respectfully and and with humanity
why isn't the president telling people
himself these images that people say
look like slavery are wrong
me as president i as president condemn
them how is he not doing that why is he
not doing that
she just sits there and kind of takes it
says
well look they're certainly not looking
out for the american people not the
press corps so keep catering to the
wrong people joe and soon
build back better will be just replaced
by
how low can he go
and that's the angle i'm steve ducey i'm
brian kilmeade and i'm ainslie earhart
and click here to subscribe to the fox
news youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis